bonjour à tous nous sommes
particulièrement heureux avec eux
guillaume pottier de vous retrouver
aujourd'hui pour ce point presse
hebdomadaire
et puis aussi un petit mot pour des
internautes qui ont la gentillesse de
regarder régulièrement ce point
d'actualité que nous faisons depuis le
siège des républicains d'abord un mot
sur l'actualité de notre mouvement avec
l'agenda hebdomadaire
aujourd'hui à 18 heures le président de
notre mouvement nicolas sarkozy
rencontrera à nouveau les syndicats de
police demain ça sera une matinée qui
sera consacrée à l'outre-mer dans le
cadre de nos matinées de travail pour le
projet des républicains piloté par eric
woerth avec un discours de nicolas
sarkozy en clôture à 12h le mercredi 1er
juin ce sera une journée importante pour
les maires de france dans le cadre du
congrès des maires de france qui a lieu
à l'heure actuelle à paris puisque les
maires républicains seront reçus au
siège ici évidemment en présence de
nicolas sarkozy avec françois baroin
présidente de l'association des maires
de france et d'hubert falco président du
comité des mères le discours de nicolas
sarkozy aura lieu à midi parallèlement
nous aurons un ce jour-là une journée
d'étude du groupe du parti populaire
européen à nice avec une intervention à
nouveau de notre président nicolas
sarkozy à 15 heures sur place ce jour là
également le mercredi 1er en fin de
journée nous aurons le rendez vous du
projet des républicains sur le thème
charge normes financement libérer les
pme pour créer de l'emploi en présence
d'eric woerth secrétaire général des
républicains et député de l'oise cela
aura lieu ici au siège
enfin jeudi 2 juin nouveaux déplacements
de notre président en province cette
fois à cannes sur la thématique de la
culture ce déplacement est en prévision
de la journée culture qui aura lieu la
semaine prochaine
ce déplacement se terminera par une
nouvelle séance de dédicaces concernant
nos conventions je le disais à l'instant
cette semaine ce sera donc la convention
journée travail sur l'outre-mer la
semaine prochaine comme je viens
d'évoquer une convention culture et
patrimoine elle n'aura lieu le 8 juin
puis la semaine suivante le 15 juin ce
sera une convention sur la thématique de
l'international et du développement
concernant les élections qui se sont
déroulées ce week-end nous voulions
évidemment nous réjouir et féliciter
notre jeune nouvelle députée des alpes
maritimes marine brenier qui a fait un
excellent score et qui pour nous
représente l'image et le rajeunissement
tels que est voulue par nicolas sarkozy
à la veille d investiture qui vont avoir
lieu vous le savez tout au long du mois
de juin pour être présenté au prochain
conseil national samedi 2 juillet
prochain donc toutes nos félicitations à
marie brenier est également une pensée
pour notre candidat jean manuel
emmanuel robert qui a fait lui un très
bon score dans la première
circonscription du bas-rhin dans une
circonscription vraiment historiquement
à gauche avec un très bon score de 46 %
enfin dans l'actualité sachez que le
mouvement cette semaine communiquera
particulièrement sur deux thématiques
sur la refonte du projet urbain avec un
nouveau tract qui rappelle justement les
engagements de nicolas sarkozy avec le
souhait de créer un euro schengen et que
la france et l'allemagne doivent
maintenant assurer le leadership de la
zone euro avec un vrai gouvernement
économique cela nous aura pas échappé
que nous en sommes loin
et puis deuxième axe de communication
la france est en état d'urgence et le
gouvernement laisse l'autorité de l'état
s'affaiblir
ça suffit ça suffit il faut restaurer
l'autorité pour mettre fin au blocage et
aux violences voici donc deux tracks qui
seront diffusées par nos militants dont
je salue ici l'engagement
sur le terrain au quotidien ici pas
besoin de mouvement en marche en marche
nous y sommes au quotidien avec les
militants les adhérents alors haut
niveau j'allais dire de l'actualité
nationale avant que bien sûr guillaume
pelletier puisse donner aussi son
appréciation sa vue sur ce que nous
avons vécu cette semaine c'est à dire
que nous sommes dans une époque de fin
de règne à quoi assistons-nous en
réalité nous assistons à un combat entre
deux faiblesses celle du gouvernement et
celle de la cgt ces deux faiblesses qui
en fait sont deux minorités c'est un
combat donc un gouvernement qui n'est
plus majoritaire dans sa propre à gauche
dans sa propre majorité j'allais dire
n'est plus majoritaire à gauche et la
cgt elle même minoritaires qui
représentent
rappelons le seulement 4% des salariés
la seule majorité en france qui existe
rappelons le dans ce pays c'est le rejet
de françois hollande et de sa politique
à nouveau les sondages nous le disent
plus personne pratiquement en france
neveu de françois hollande et le rejet
de la cgt et le rejet de françois
hollande dans l'eure jusqu'au boutiste
sont en train d'entraîner la france sur
une pente particulièrement dangereuse le
gouvernement et la cgt ont fait le choix
de la confrontation
c'est une stratégie qui est du perdant
perdant perdant pour eux à un moment ou
un autre mais surtout perdant pour les
français au moment où l'on pouvait
espérer une amélioration sur le terrain
de l'emploi et au moment où grâce à
l'influencé de facteurs extérieurs que
nous connaissons tous maintenant la
baisse de l'euro un pétrole bas des taux
d'intérêt à zéro et bien cette chance-là
est en train d'être mise à mal d'être
mise à mal de manière absolument
inadmissible la fragilité est devenue
maintenant la signature de tout acte
engagé par ce gouvernement est là
tuation que nous connaissons maintenant
depuis trois mois de manifestations
incessantes de violences incessantes de
blocage qui sont récurrents et
maintenant de la perte de carburant ou
en tout cas le rationnement du carburant
ou nous voyons une semaine de tous les
dangers qui s'annonce ce climat de
tension et ravageur pour notre pays
il est d'abord ravageur pour les
français et nous allons revenir là
dessus et les ravageurs pour l'image de
la france à l'étranger
nous sommes en train de payer de manière
dramatique les mensonges de françois
hollande
et c'est lourd évidemment de
conséquences pour des millions de
français je voudrais aussi revenir un
instant sur l'attractivité de la france
et sur le danger que son et à la veille
de l'euro 2016 de ce qui est en train de
se passer nous sommes en ce moment en
europe en train de gagner des parts de
marché les investisseurs commençaient à
revenir 15% de plus d'investisseurs sur
le marché européen
l'année dernière et parallèlement 2% de
moins pour la france
est ce qu'il n'est pas temps aussi de
faire attention quand les investisseurs
étrangers sont en train de se détourner
de notre territoire pour plutôt aller
vers l'allemagne vers le royaume uni
voire la pologne ou encore la roumanie
ça mille projets de l'année dernière sur
le territoire européen et la france qui
n'est pas capable de répondre présent
est-ce que la situation et l'image que
nous donnons à l'heure actuelle de la
france va inciter les investisseurs
étrangers la réponse est évidemment non
et avant l'euro 2016 quelles
responsabilités
sommes nous en train de prendre quelle
responsabilité prend le gouvernement
quelles responsabilités sont en train de
prendre les syndicats particulièrement
la cgt et fo
nous voulons aussi à la veille de cette
semaine de tous les dangers
avoir une pensée pour tous ceux qui
n'arrivent pas à se faire entendre pour
les petits artisans pour les petites et
moyennes entreprises pour les
agriculteurs pour les professions
libérales pour les hôteliers pour les
restaurateurs pour tous ceux qui
attendent que survive qui attendent de
travailler et qui pour la paix
part d'entre eux auront peut-être des
difficultés à finir leurs fins de mois
et comment ne pas aussi avoir une pensée
pour tout simplement ceux qui n'ont pas
de travail alors cette france qui va
mieux et dont se targue monsieur
hollande est tout simplement un fantasme
de sa part ce françois hollande qui
voulait rentrer dans l'histoire
et qui a dit être entré dans l'histoire
je ne pense pas non plus que ce soit
avec ce qui s'est passé hier un verdun
que nous serons rassurés les français
aujourd'hui sont en galère ils sont pour
la plupart d'entre eux dans le silence
quand il aimerait tout simplement
continuer à travailler
je voudrais laisser peut-être aussi la
parole bien sûr à guillaume mais nous
dire que cette situation nous mais en
responsabilité nous les républicains par
rapport à la situation du pays et nous
sommes conscients de la tante de ce
besoin d'alternance dans ce pays
ce besoin nous y répondons semaine après
semaine
en travaillant sur un projet avec des
conventions à la fin du mois sera
présenté notre projet plus exactement le
2 juillet nous sommes en ordre de marche
avec un projet qui devra répondre aux
attentes tant au niveau économique et
social cette pensée est pour part dans
cette responsabilité c'est également ce
que nous disait nicolas sarkozy pour
l'avenir c'est à dire tout dire
maintenant pour faire tout après cet
engagement là c'est le nôtre et nous
allons continuer à faire en sorte d'être
à la hauteur des attentes des français
merci brigitte bonjour à tous comment tu
as très bien résumé est synthétisée
l'état d'esprit de nos compatriotes en
ces temps troublés est vrai qu'on est
tout cela à la veille d'une semaine
ô combien crucial et est importante pour
nos concitoyens pour notre pays et tous
les événements aussi différents soit il
d'ailleurs des derniers jours et des
jours à venir
tendent à démontrer combien françois
hollande manuel valls l'ensemble du
gouvernement incarne de plus en plus une
politique de mensonge d'incompétence
d'indécence et même de gribouille tant
l'opacité domine sur la quasi totalité
des sujets on peut prendre tous ceux du
week-end on peut prendre ceux qui vont
arriver dans l'est dans les prochains
jours le premier sentiment très fort de
nos compatriotes
c'est le sentiment d'abandon et de pâtes
d'opacité par rapport aux à la loi
travail plus personne n'y comprend rien
ça fait des mois et des mois que nous
débattons sur cette question cette loi a
été vidé de sa substance
nous avons perdu l'opportunité
extraordinaire d'en faire une loi au
service des entrepreneurs et des
travailleurs
nous sommes dans un débat qui ne
correspond même plus aux attentes de nos
compatriotes qui ne correspond même plus
un débat entre la gauche et la droite
même plus un débat strictement sein de
la gauche mais un débat au sein du parti
socialiste entre tel ou tel ténors du
gouvernement ou du parti est pire
après cette vraie-fausse loi elle
conneries nous arrivons désormais à une
semaine de tous les blocages puisque
dans quelques heures et dans quelques
jours après les l'insupportable attente
liée au blocage des raffineries et
l'incapacité du gouvernement malgré la
question des dépôts de carburant de
réquisitionner les personnels des
raffineries comme nous le demandions la
semaine dernière et comme nicolas
sarkozy d'ensemble du gouvernement
l'avait fait en octobre 2010 avec
courage empêchant par là le blocage de
notre pays nous allons avoir la ronde
indécente la danse indécente des
manifestations et des blocages de tous
les privilégiés et de tous les protégés
de notre pays
grève à la sncf grève à la ratp grève
dans les aéroports
j'en passe et des pires tout ça pour
démontrer que ce gouvernement ne parle
plus aux français
et ça fait longtemps ne parle même plus
aux sympathisants de gauche on voit leur
défiance s'accroître jour après jour
mais ne fait que s'adresser à des
minorités bloquantes dont nous aimerions
avec brigitte et au nom des républicains
rappelé
l'incroyable protection de leur statut
qu'il se propose de défendre tout au
long de la semaine
quelques chiffres que soient les
chiffres des rapports sénatoriaux ou des
du conseil national de l'assurance
vieillesse par exemple il faut que les
français sachent que les agents de la
ratp qui vont manifester cette semaine
ont le privilège de partir en moyenne à
la retraite à l'âge de 54 ans cinq ans
que les agents de sncf qui vont se faire
grève et bloqué notre pays on incroyable
privilège en 2016 de partir à la
retraite à 55 ans par rapport à une
moyenne de départ à la retraite pour nos
compatriotes de 62 ans
il faut que nos compatriotes sachent
aussi que cette minorité qui va bloquer
notre pays dans les jours et les heures
qui viennent
en s'en prenant d'abord aux plus
modestes aux travailleurs à celles et
ceux qui du matin au soir tente
justement de travailler et de continuer
à développer l'esprit d'entreprise de
mérite et d'efforts dans notre pays il
faut que les français sachent que chaque
année par nos impôts
l'état fait un chèque je prends
l'exemple de la sncf 2 3 milliards 300
millions d'euros pour équilibrer les
comptes de la sncf la sncf par exemple
que les français le sachent
là aussi c'est donc des agents qui
partent à la retraite huit à neuf ans
avant la moyenne de nos compatriotes
ce sont des agents est une entreprise
qui reçoit un chèque de plus de 3
milliards d'euros chaque année
payés par les impôts des contribuables
français
et c'est une entreprise comme la ratp
d'ailleurs qui bénéficie selon le
rapport courageux
du député courageux que fut n'est que
nicolas perruchot qui bénéficient de
décharge ou d'heures de décharge de
fonctionnaires estimé pour les trois
fonctions publiques à près de trente
mille fonctionnaires équivalents temps
plein voilà la réalité dans notre pays
et voilà celles et ceux qui vont se
permettre de bloquer notre pays dans les
heures et les jours qui viennent cela
suffit et donc au nom des républicains
nous demandons à travers un ultimatum
solennelle et grave à françois hollande
à manuel valls et au gouvernement de
prendre leurs responsabilités
cette semaine c'est maintenant ou jamais
c'est cette semaine ou jamais car chacun
sait que dès la semaine d'après à
l'honneur de la france nous
accueillerons l'une des plus grandes
cérémonies sportive au monde
le championnat d'europe de football et
qu'il est indispensable pour les
français eux mêmes et pour l'image de la
france au niveau européen et
international que la situation soit
rétablie et que l'autorité de l'état
soit assumé cette politique de
gribouille d'incompétence et d'indécence
permettez-moi de l'étendre et de
l'élargir non pas simplement à la loi
travail non pas simplement au blocage
qui pèsent sur notre pays depuis
plusieurs semaines et qui vont
s'aggraver tout au long de la semaine
qui vient
mais à d'autres évènements que vous
pourriez à tort jugés comme plus
marginaux ou secondaire nous avons été
les uns et les autres
scandalisé par le choix de l'elysée
si j'en crois vos confrères de bfm tv ce
matin de la scénographie de verdun à
verdun l'elysée françois hollande
scénographe allemand et un certain
nombre de responsables dont j'aimerais
d'ailleurs bien connaître les noms et
puis surtout les moyens financiers
qu'ils ont reçus ont jugé élégant deux
faits
recourir dans une sorte de jogging
improvisé des milliers de jeunes au sein
de l'ossuaire de douaumont
il ne faut ne jamais avoir eu la chance
de parcourir les cimetières et ses zones
abîmées par l'histoire de verdun de
douaumont et de tant d'autres villages
martyrs pour ne pas anticiper juger et
jauger l'indécence d'un tel choix
ces lieux requiert pour toujours le
silence le recueillement la décence
le respect dû à celles et ceux qui ont
sacrifié leur vie pour notre liberté
comme disaient les poètes et les
écrivains
ces hommes et ces femmes trois cent
mille français et allemand cent mille
sans aucune sépulture ont souffert en
silence et sont morts en silence pour
que nous puissions vivre libres et bien
moi au nom des républicains avec
brigitte et l'ensemble de nos élus nous
dénonçons cette indécence qui fait
croire que tout se vaut et que par des
scènes indécentes et irrespectueuse on
peut se vautrer dans la mémoire la
mémoire que nous devons aux héros de
verdun mérite et commande le respect le
silence et le recueillement
et cela fait partie aussi de cette
incapacité du gouvernement et de
françois hollande à saisir avec
délicatesse maturité authenticité
l'esprit de la france c'est la même
chose dans un autre registre
si vous me le permettez de cet autre
indécence celle portée en costume ou en
t-shirt je ne sais plus par monsieur
emmanuel macron tout au long du week end
qui prétend se mettre en marche avec des
milliers de marcheurs fantôme
et je lance un appel à emmanuel macron
dont j'entends ici ou là les idées sur
l'économie sur la réforme sociale ce le
soutien aux entreprises
nous aimerions que monsieur emmanuel
macron soit le ministre de l'économie et
des finances c'est vraiment dommage
qu'ils ne soient pas le ministre de
l'économie et des finances lui qui
prétend avoir de si belles idées sur
l'économie par delà cette formule pleine
d'ironie
vous comprendrez que les français ne
supportent plus à travers monsieur
macron ce fossé ce précipice cet océan
entre les paroles et les actes
il prétend au quotidien soutenir les pme
défendre les travailleurs réformer notre
pays est bien plutôt que de faire le
malin en marchant benoîtement et
bêtement dans les rues de france à la
recherche de ce que pensent les français
nous n'avons pas besoin de faire nous le
savons nous les vivons et nous les
croisons au quotidien nos compatriotes
nous demandons à emmanuel macron
d'assumer la fonction qui lui a été
confié il est à la tête d'un des plus
grands ministères français
il est à la tête de l'économie française
il est à terre la tête de bercy
il est le ministre de l'économie et des
finances plutôt que de penser à lui même
à son propre ego est plutôt que de faire
croire à l'aune des quarante ans qu'il
peut enfin rencontrer la france
nous aimerions qu'ils puissent
rencontrer dignement la responsabilité
qui lui a été confié et qu'il assume ses
fonctions de ministre de l'économie et
des finances à travers tous ces
événements verdun la petite marche des
manuels macron la vraie-fausse l'ol
comrie les blocages insupportable que
vivent et veut que vont continuer à
vivre nos compatriotes c'est bien
l'incompétence l'indécence le mauvais
goût qu'incarnent aujourd'hui le
gouvernement et nous lui réclamant à
travers les jours qui viennent une prise
de conscience sur la gravité de la
situation
sion et qu'il puisse remettre la france
à l'endroit et retrouvée ce que méritent
les français c'est à dire le chemin de
l'autorité de la clarté du courage et de
l'audace